yo what's going on guys crispy flakes
here of bleacher report and for today's
video we are checking out ranking every
nba starting lineup post trade deadline
so the nba trade deadline is a good
opportunity to trade for a player that
hopefully moves your team in the right
direction winning nba championship or
it's an opportunity to solve some assets
and set yourself up for a future rebuild
right man so as we go through this list
here i'll just keep in mind if your team
isn't ranked where you would like them
to be it's because you know in the
moment they're not really built to win a
championship but they might have a
really fantastic future so let's go
ahead get going on this man starting
with team number 30 the okc thunder so
we all know the thunder are set up for a
beautiful rebuild so many draft picks
out there josh getty is an absolute stud
as a rook you got shake guilt alexander
dorts of beasts so yeah while the team
is ranked 30th due to their net rating
uh they're still set up for a very
bright future so you can't really be
upset about this even in this case you
honestly probably want to be one of the
worst teams if you're into rebuild
because then you have a better chance at
a higher draft pick right man so okay
see great future man just in the moment
you know still learning a few things uh
next up we got my favorite basketball
team the detroit pistons right here and
uh yeah when it comes down to the
detroit pistons right now they got the
worst record in the nba they look like
they're gonna get a top top five pick
again but uh you know with the exception
of riven and marvin bagley uh this team
is still quite a few you know pieces of
the way kate cunningham is a great
foundation loves to debate but in the
moment uh yeah negative 9.8 net rating
for the detroit pistons
next up we do have the new york knicks
so this one right here man the knicks um
prime definition of you know sometimes
you make certain moves and it just makes
the team worse so right now uh negative
13.4 net rating and uh this lineup of
canva evan 40 rg bear jewish randall
mitchell robinson just really isn't it
man you know kemba a shell of his former
self defensively atrocious and uh you
know bringing like evan forney to just
to be an additional shot taking around
the team julius randle is kind of
regressed this season no he actually has
regressed so uh yeah man the foundation
is r.j barrett maybe the drops and then
resign him he will be topping manual
quickly great future but i do know that
nick fans they were expecting a lot more
this season out of this team uh next up
we do have the portland trailblazers so
this is the prime example of n a not
enough possessions uh we just don't know
the net net rating of is of this
starting five uh on friendly simon's
josh hart um cj justice and nerdkitch
out there and i mean like last game um
you know simons and hart looked
fantastic together so that could be a
little promising but uh i would say you
know based off the starting five i'm not
expecting a lot of wins coming out of it
which gives him that 27 spot and uh
obviously be a bit better too you know
if damien lillard comes back healthy but
he might be out for the rest of the
season man we're not really sure about
that uh next up we got the houston
rockets so they got a negative 0.4 net
rating
i think a lot of it is you know what for
one you're incorporating a rookie guard
and jalen green into the lineup but also
you know you got the kevin porter
experiment of him at point guard and uh
once again a team that has a bright
future they drafted fantastically last
you know nba offseason but in the moment
you know a lot of young players i guess
you got a veteran eric gordon but for
the most part a lot of young players
making you know young player mistakes
uh next up we got the washington wizards
this is raul neto kcp kyle kuzma uh
chris hopps porzingis and daniel gafford
um once again not enough possessions we
have not seen chris thompson with this
team yet but i mean the way kuzma's been
playing kcp you know a former champion
3d type of guy out there uh next season
is when this team really could blossom
by adding bradley beal but it comes down
to chris stop staying healthy and uh
when it comes down to porzingis that's
always the question is like it's always
next year chris hops will be healthy man
but uh he's got to stay healthy for the
squad i mean i love the i love him next
to gafford like that just works for a
front court in my opinion okay next up
we got the indiana pacers and uh not
enough possessions with them but what i
will say is tyreese halliburton looks
like a future superstar no doubt uh this
starting five right here man just so fun
so quick but also has a direction now
right man like you have a direction with
this team knowing that you know they're
not playing right now to win
championships or make the playoffs
they're playing just to you know get
better get that chemistry going and uh
the pacers no longer stuck in that no
man's land like they have they're doing
halliburton let's see how the future
goes in the moment you know it'll be fun
to watch uh next up we got the orlando
magic with cole anthony jalen suggs
franz wendell and mo bamba so a plus 2.2
net rating a kind of an unorthodox
lineup you know you kind of essentially
have two centers in the front court uh
you have two point guards in the
backcourt and uh yeah that's a good
reason for their 23rd ranking right here
man but a lot of good pieces just in the
future you got to find that optimal
lineup and trade for the optimal guys to
uh get that net rating even higher uh
next we do have the sacramento kings
with fox mitchell holiday harrison
barnes and sabonis um i do expect this
team to even increase even more of their
net range just because sabonis is an
all-star player the this trade you know
you might be against it but it was a
win-now move uh in the sense of not win
a championship now but you know win some
more basketball games which i think
kings fans would just be okay with that
at this point so
um yeah i think this starting five has a
lot of potential going forward it just
in my opinion you know you have enough
shooters around fox and some bonus um
that i think just works in the future
man and i'm excited to see where this
team goes uh over the course of the next
few seasons having you know two all-star
caliber players in sabonis and darren
fox and essentially even harrison barnes
i mean he could be that type of guy at
times uh next up we got the clippers at
21 and uh you know
let's get this case we got reggie norm
powell paul george marcus morris and
zubots right here you know paul george
is going to bring that up a lot just
being um you know mvp caliber player
hopefully he's back before the end of
the season because you know you do add
paul george and kawhi leonard once he's
healthy and back in this clippers team
um in the short term man it's gonna be
fantastic it's just the team's got to
get healthy all around
and uh hopefully that it's not a what if
you know 10 years down the road we're
looking back and being like yeah we
never really got to see paul jordan
quiet too much um but no like on paper
the team's fantastic just got to stay
healthy uh next up we got the los
angeles lakers i know laker fans are not
happy about this right here because they
did not sign russell westbrook or trade
firm should i say with the mindset of
being the 20th best um you know ranked
team in the nba but fact of the matter
starting five just really doesn't work
and i know personally i know russell
westbrook's trade value is not very high
but i was hoping they would have done
something man something and i know
they're hoping to get like a dennis
schruter in the bio market
but uh yeah this team just did not
really do anything to trade down line
and for a team that has lebron james who
is old
um
i was hoping for a little bit more
because any seasons that's not a
championship season for lebron james is
a wasted year um next we have the san
antonio spurs at 19. you know you got
the all-star and the john dean murray
you got the young buck and kelden
johnson devon vasel uh this team i still
think needs a few more pieces they
should get that you know via um the
draft lottery this next nba all season
but what you see at the starting lineup
is just a good foundation and sometimes
that's what you need and you know the
spurs are built on foundation they're
they're they're built on consistency
good fluid ball movement man and uh
hopefully you know with murray out there
keller johnson that's a step towards
that greatness that the spurs fans are
used to back from the tim duncan days uh
next up we got number 18 the charlotte
hornets with lamello terry rozier gordon
hayward miles bridges and mason plumlee
so as far as this going for a starting
five um with the exception of mason
plugley he was pretty useless
offensively uh i guess you can catch
some laps and stuff like that but you
know you have a mellow ball who is just
next level superstar point guard caliber
and everything and uh you have them
surrounded with these different pieces
that you know you got the veterans and
scary terry gordon hayward we also got
miles bridges taking such a huge step
this season not only in the stat
department but having those stairs
actually lead to meaningful you know
wins um
for his team so yeah the team's got
great you know great potential going
forward man and i'm excited to see what
happens with it next up we got number 17
the atlanta hawks with trey young kevin
here deandre hunter john collins and
clint capela so me personally like the
way this starting five is orchestrated
is the exact same way that i would
personally build a basketball team man
i'm talking about you know back in the
day doing uh association mode on 2k and
stuff like that man you got the
playmaking point guard you got the
shooter at the two you got the jack of
all trades and deandre hunter you got
the athletic stretch at the fourth spot
and you got the cleanup man on the
inside um
once again the hawks are another team
this season that have underperformed but
i think potentially man uh they can
really be good so i like that starting
five next up we got the pelicans with
devante graham cj mccollum brain ingram
herbert jones and jonas felicinus uh yes
cj's been really nice man like he's
always been somebody that's had the same
skill set as damian lillard but the
issue is that he played with damian
lillard so it was always masked by
damien lillard's greatness now cj really
has an opportunity to just bring this
pelicans team together but we're missing
one guy to get this team moved up even
higher and that's gonna be zion
williamson
uh next up we got the dallas mavericks
so you know the mavericks did do a
shocking trade getting rid of porzingis
but at the same time uh using that
rating and everything the plus minus
with chris stops and luka doncic on the
court together uh i believe was actually
worse than luca just not playing with
chris stops so
let's call like it is you know getting
uh spencer didn't witty and also davos
burtons uh those are two guys that
incorporated correctly could in theory
make this maverick seem a lot better man
so um i'm curious what the starting five
is gonna be like going forward if it is
going to be this right here dorian
finney you know just sign that extension
everything it looks like it should be it
um although i wouldn't be totally
against you know dinwiddie being used as
like a six-man point guard and maybe
even putting uh maxi or davis into the
lineup just for that additional spacing
because dinwiddie is the guy who knew
the ball in his hands but doesn't really
shoot the greatest all the time
especially this season uh next up we got
the toronto raptors loved how this team
is built here man fred van blee gary
trent scottie barnes og and pascal
siacom never been a huge fan of pascal
at the five spot but as of late he's
been just he's been on next level man
like i was shocked that he did not make
any of the injury reserves for the
all-star game
but what i do know is this raptors team
is fun pascal looks like he's ready to
be the man in toronto and uh just
surrounded by so much you know great
talent right here man like this team is
gonna be scary and not a team you want
to see come play off time next up we do
have the chicago bulls uh lonzo levine
jovante demar derozan and vucevic
what more could be said here man like
people were so concerned if this team
was gonna fit and i think it fits
perfectly like just the way these guys
and their skill sets and the way they
play off each other and everything i
know they've been dealing with injuries
and everything like a lot of teams have
been but uh when this team is full
strength um to me they're number one
number two in the eastern conference in
my opinion for win the championship man
or at least making it to the finals i
really believe in this bulls team uh
next up we do have the phoenix suns
chris paul devin booker mikel j crowler
deandre ayton yeah no surprise here this
team made it to the finals um cp3 always
says any team design you'll run like a
well-oiled machine and this team is
really no exception man uh next up we
have the denver nuggets and this is
assuming full health with jamal murray
will barton michael porter aaron gordon
and uh jokic so jokic by himself has
been been carrying this team this season
man and jamal and michael porter should
be back hopefully before the playoffs
and once they do uh assuming they're
fully healthy i hope you know if
somebody like michael porter does not
rush himself back just to play because
we know to start the season he um
was having some injury issues and
playing through it and he was just
really bad so don't do that but when
completely healthy we do know the
potential of this nuggets team and if
they can stay healthy once again a team
you do not want to see in the playoffs
man whatsoever if they can pull it all
together um next up we do have the
cleveland cavaliers so i think they have
one of the most underrated moves in
bringing his character levert i just
think he is just like this i don't know
man just like this beacon added to this
team of just what they needed like they
lost ricky rubio colin sexton's been out
all season and you just bring in the
former the former you know ohio native
and charis levert and it's just fun man
like he just provides scoring but not in
a way that's going to take away from
everybody else i just think he's good
you know chemistry wise for this team uh
next up we got the utah jazz with mike
conley mitchell royal boyan byganovich
and rudy gobert um a lot of that we've
seen for years now and uh not years but
you know last few seasons and uh this
team always performs nicely you know in
the regular season and while they're top
10 here in this ranking we all know when
it comes down to the jazz it's about
doing it in the playoffs right hopefully
they have enough to do so but starting
five wise um yeah one of the best in the
nba um next up we have the milwaukee
bucks with uh drew holliday grayson
allen
chris milton ganes and bobby portis so
yeah brook lopez has had issues with
injuries all season uh that's just a big
part of what this team has been in years
past and everything which is probably
why the ratings at eight
but uh they were probably a little bit
higher you know if rick lopez was
healthy and everything but fact of the
matter once again another team that uh
you know champions last year i mean
like playoff giannis scares me i just
it's hard for me to ever think that a
team is now going to be playoff giannis
but uh we'll see what happens uh when
the post season rolls around
number seven we do have the miami heat
uh for the most part you know good and
healthy now we're waiting for old depot
to come back with this starting five i
it it just screams my heat basketball
it's got that grit and grind factor to
it um it's got that toughness it's got
that spacing it's got everything man in
the miami heat i think are going to be
on a huge huge run for this uh last part
of the season going into the playoffs uh
number six we got the memphis grizzlies
i would say right up there you know you
could say the cleveland cavaliers or the
memphis grizzlies is the most surprising
team since nba season probably cleveland
first because nobody expected it but
memphis what they've been doing and uh
just guys like desmond bain that were
drafted what like last pick of the first
round
of his draft class and looking like a
future nba all-star caliber player you
got john ranches
with his athleticism building to get to
the basket but also penetrating great
place for others oh man i love it this
grizzlies team is set up for so much
success in the future and in the moment
too uh number five we have the
timberwolves right here with dlo patrick
beverly ant-man jared and kat and not
gonna lie man like whenever i see the
toronto i'm sorry the middle school
t-wolves like this
it always catches me off guard because
we're you know we're used to them under
performing but it seems like those times
are behind us now this team just
especially patrick beverly i feel like
he's been just such a good vocal leader
for this team and just kind of given him
that veteran presence that they were
kind of lacking that toughness but in a
way that uh what we all know didn't
really work out with jimmy butler and
cat and stuff like that but i think
patrick beverly does it in a very
just uh connective way that really has
this team well as it says top five uh
when it comes down to net rating number
four we got the philadelphia 76ers this
is gonna be really interesting man uh we
don't have enough possessions to give
them a net rating but
i'm so curious how james hard and joel
embiid can go because
we do know you know on paper it sounds
like it's a good duo but we also know
that both these guys got uh very uh
bodacious personalities man maybe i
don't know bodacious is the word it's
not like a good fancy word but uh just
different personalities too in the sense
that
you know they like to have fun but also
if things don't go their way it can lead
to some clashing heads right so you
trade ben simmons you kind of get
another big personal james harden i just
hope it works out uh number three we do
have the brooklyn edge right here kyrie
seth curry kevin durant ben simmons and
andre drummond um i wish drummond could
shoot because they would literally be
the perfect team it would be the perfect
team or i guess i wish ben simmons could
shoot too but uh yeah that's we all know
how that all goes but man like ben
simmons is handling that basketball you
know a little pick and roll with andre
drummond with kyrie seth and durant on
the perimeter or whatnot
whoo man it could be dangerous uh number
two we have the boston celtics
and uh yeah this is probably one of the
teams we have one of the biggest sample
size with because we've seen this type
of lineup for them so many times in
years past um
and they've honestly been killing it as
of late right man like they have been
one of the better teams in the nba um i
love the jalen and jason duo i don't
think the celtics should ever get rid of
that and it seems like the lineups are
working now going forward uh we'll see
how that all goes but in the moment man
boston celtics slow start to the season
but it's all about how you finish right
uh the number one we do have the golden
state warriors literally just the
definition of picture perfect basketball
uh just a well oiled machine yet again
here man like we know what this warriors
team is all about we know you know being
coached by steve curry and also ran by
steph curry you know draymond green that
you are meant for success man so that's
all we have for this video um give me
your thoughts about these rankings right
here you know once again keep in mind a
lot of them are just based off of not
having enough possessions not seeing a
lot of it so it's speculation based but
at the same time um it's all about the
mindset about where the team is headed
going forward but also what they're
doing this season too right man so thank
you all so much for watching and peace
out